[Musique]
c'est au siège historique de la Chambre
de Commerce de Paris que la présidente
du département Nassima nindar a reçu le
Prix culture et loisirs du parish shop
and design 2016 ce prix récompense la
boutique de la réunion située à
l'antenne de Paris pour son design et la
présentation artistique des objets
artisanaux présents dans cette boutique
recevoir un prix sur le plan nation pour
la vitrine la boutique de de la réunion
à Paris c'est d'abord une fieré pour
nous pour l'ensemble des réunonnais sur
le savoir-faire que nous avons et puis
aussi sur le contenu même de la boutique
avec les produits pays la filier à boî
goyavier et son design c'est c'est un
prix design et shop shop et design ça
montre bien que sur le commerce et ben
là réunion a un vrai savoir-faire et
puis la Chambre de Commerce de Paris qui
honore au fond par avec un un jury de
qualité qui qui qui vote pour nous et
qui reconnaît que cette boutique elle a
une certaine originalité et ben je crois
que la réunion nous sommes fiers
pourquoi parce que elle représente la
diversité
française sur le bout de l'océan Indien
parce que nous sommes la France de
l'océan indien et
que petit cailloux dans l'océan Indien
avec la capitale ici à Paris cette belle
représentation c'est véritablement une
reconnaissance et pour la boutique et
pour l'ensemble du savoir-faire
réunionné euh on a trouvé d'abord que le
projet était magnifique il avait une
recherche très intéressante sur les
matériaux surtout ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant c'était de
voir que c'est a priori un lieu très
institutionnel et justement tous les
codes de ce genre de lieu là a été
bouleversé que c'était vraiment un lieu
qui voulait refléter l'île de la Réunion
et et faire vivre cette expérience de de
la réunion à donner envie d'y aller de
la qui l'a fait rayonner aussi dans
Paris puisque on a la chance
effectivement de pouvoir avoir ce genre
de belle boutique dans Paris aussi la
boutique de la Réunion a séduit le jury
du Prix culture et loisirs pour son
origin
et la diversité de ces matériaux c'est
pour le Conseil départemental le moyen
de mettre en avant la filière boî
goyavier et tout de suite ça a pris une
envergure 12 personnes 40 50 aujourd'hui
autour de cette je veis dire cette
microofilière de la production à la
distribution bah on est autour des 150
personnes direct en indir il y en a qui
coupent qui collectent il y en a qui qui
transforment la matière et il y en a qui
qu' le distribue tel qu'on a quelques
boutiques à la Réunion pour vendre pour
vendre du du du produit d'où maintenant
à Paris c'est c'est une grande fierté
c'est une grande fierté pour cette
équipe et la panoplie des des produits
elle va du
petitile en passant par le mobilier de
jardin de la maison et autour aussi de
de de cette forme d'hébergement insolite
ou ce bois qui est une qui d'ailleurs
m'a intéressé
de par ses caractéristiques et sa nature
c'est une espèce
envahissante et de ce fait le Conseil
Général détient 80 % des des forêts
départementaux de Manial à la Réunion
d'où pour moi c'était il y avait une
richesse le bois pauvre il a été anobli
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce prix décerné au à la
collectivité je dirais cette récompense
offre une visibilité nationale et
internationale du savoirfire réunionner
la boutique de la Réunion fait désormais
partie des plus belles vitrines des
commerces
[Musique]
parisiens